HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER- I
BELIEVE WE DO NOT AS OF YET HAVE
A QUORUM. SO WE WILL WAIT UNTIL
SUCH TIME AS YOU DID CALL THE
ROLL- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
WELCOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENT AND MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO
TODAY'S HEARING. WE HAVE TEN
BILLS ON FILE. OKAY LET ME START
OVER. YEAH WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THIS AWAY TO CALL THE PUT THE
GAVEL DOWN TO WE HAVE A QUORUM-
OR CALL THE ROLL TO WE HAVE A
QUORUM RATHER- UNLIKE IN WELCOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC TO TODAY'S HEARING WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON FILE PLEASE
NOTE THAT WILL DO THE HEARING
BILLS AND FILE. ORDER THEREFORE
MEASURES ON CONSENT THEY ARE AB
1-028-321-8740 WITH AMENDMENTS.
AND AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. WE
ALSO A SPECIAL ORDER FOR ONE
BILL AB FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR RAMOS
MISTER RAMOS WHICH WILL BE
PRESENTED FOR TESTIMONY ONLY
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE ON THAT
TODAY. BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR CHEN
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
HAVE A NEW VICE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEGAN
DALI AS WELL AS A NEW MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAN BUT THEY'RE
NOT HERE. SO MR CHOI IS GOING TO
BE JOINING US TODAY SITTING IN
FOR THEM. SO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI. FINALLY I HAVE A
STATEMENT TO READ REGARDING OUR
PROCESS THE ASSEMBLY IS
REQUIRING THAT MATTHEW WORN BY
PEOPLE PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM. IF YOU DO NOTHAVE UNLESS
WE WILL PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE
ALSO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND AS A RESULT THERE ARE A
LIMITED. NUMBER OF SEATS.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
WELCOME TO WRITE COMMENT IN
PERSON AND THROUGH THE BOOTH
POSITIONED LETTER PORT ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE SO YOU DON'T
PERSON OR YOU CAN SUBMIT A
LETTER. TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE
THERE IS A PORTAL THERE FOR YOU
TO SUBMIT. TESTIMONY A LOT OF
DIFFERENT EUROPEAN. WITH THAT WE
WILL PROCEED. TO OUR SPECIAL
ORDER IN HER FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB FIFTEEN FIFTY MORE
FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS IS HE
PRESENT. MYSTERONS YOU MAY COME
UP PLEASE. IN THIS PRESENTATION
AS FORD TESTIMONY ONLY THERE
WILL BE NO VOTE AGAIN IT'S I
FOUND NUMBER ONE AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED ONE
READY MISTER RAMOS. WELL THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- OVER THE PAST
pSEVERAL MONTHS WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED SAD REMINDERS ABOUT
THE NEED TO INCREASE KNOWLEDGE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY AND
CULTURE IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS.
IN OCTOBER A TEACHER OR FAKE
INDIAN HEADDRESS AND HOPPED
AROUND THE CLASS AND MISGUIDED
EFFORT TO HELP OUR STUDENTS-
REMEMBER MATH PRINCIPLES. ALSO
IN OCTOBER AND THEN LATER IN
NOVEMBER THE NEW YORK TIMES
PUBLISHED TWO STORIES ABOUT IN
FAMOUS FOUNDER OF THE HASTINGS
LAW SCHOOL. THAT TALE THAT THEY
TOLD IN THERE TOLD OF THE
KILLING SPREE THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL PERPETRATED AGAINST
THE UK- INDIAN PEOPLE AND AROUND
VALLEY TRIBES TO SEIZE THEIR
LAND. I AND TO CONTINUE TO GAIN
WEALTH THESE TYPES OF HISTORY IS
NOT BEING TAUGHT WITHIN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS ABOUT THE TRUE
HISTORY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO IN APRIL OF
FORMER PENNSYLVANIA SENATOR RICK
SANTORUM WAS WIDELY CONDEMNED
AND LOST HIS CNN JOB. AFTER
SAYING THAT SETTLERS. BIRTH THE
NATION FROM NOTHING. AND HE WAS
QUOTED TO SAY I MEAN THERE WAS
NOTHING HERE I MEAN YES WE HAVE
NATIVE AMERICANS BUT CANDIDLY
THERE ISN'T MUCH NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE. IN AMERICAN. THE
CULTURE ITSELF TODAY. THESE
TYPES OF AREAS THE TYPES OF
STATE CAN. TO PLAGUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND NATION.
IN THE SENSE. REFER ABOUT. AND
IGNORE SIRENS. TOWARD A PEEP
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE. INDIVIDUAL TRIBAL
MEMBERS IN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION WITH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED TRIES BEING REPRESENTED
WELL EACH ONE WITH ITS OWN
CULTURE AND LANGUAGE. OUR STATE
HAS THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
NATIVE AMERICANS AND THEY ARE
WIDELY DISPERSED- WITH MORE THAN
70% LIVING IN URBAN AREAS. THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT POPULATION AND
IT'S A NUMBER ONE POPULATION IN
THE NATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. MANY OF THE HIGHWAYS
THAT WE SEE TODAY AND TRAVEL
WERE ONCE INDIAN TRAILS THAT
CONTINUE TO BE ROUTES FOR STATE
AND HIGHWAY FIVE. ONE OH ONE AND
MANY OF THOSE AREAS THAT YET IS
IT BEING TOLD AND THE HISTORY
BEING TOLD IN THE SCHOOLS ITSELF
. IN OCTOBER- THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS HELD A JOINT
HEARING. WE HEARD FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON IN A PARTICULAR
STATE SENATOR JOHN MCCOY. WHO
SAID THAT HIS STATE'S EFFORT TO
TEACH A MORE COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE HISTORY OF ITS TRIBES
BEGAN WITH SCHOOLS REACHING OUT
TO THE TRIBES WHO LIVE IN THEIR
AREA. WE ALSO HEARD FROM
CHAIRMAN KENNETH KAHN FROM SANTA
YNEZ TRIBAL GOVERNMENT CENTER
WEBER WITH THE SAMBAR DINO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
MARGARET ROBBINS FROM THE
KLAMATH TRINITY JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND JUDY FLORES
AND CHAIRMAN JACK CARTER FROM
SHASTA COUNTY. THEY SHARED
EXAMPLES OF HOW TRIBES IN
SCHOOLS INTERACT IN A POSITIVE
CONSISTENT RELATIONSHIP BUILDING
MATTER. AND THE RESULTING
POSITIVE STUDENT OUTCOMES FOR
ALL STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON. IT CAN BE DONE AND
ONE IS DONE RIGHT ALL STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES BENEFIT. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE STRIVING
FOR HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. JUST AS ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT
ABOUT ANCIENT GREEK AND ROMAN
EFFORTS AT DEMOCRACY. ALL
STUDENTS SHOULD ALSO BE TAUGHT
ABOUT THE EARLY AND ONGOING
EFFORTS OF COLONIZATION. TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. THEY
SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO HAVE A-
INTO THE TRAVEL GO STE. WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT FOR STE LOW
GOVERNMENTS TRY WILL GO.
SOVEREIGN GO. SHOULD BE PART OF
THAT EQUATION AS WELL AS THE
HISTORY THE HISTORY THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT- EARLY ON WITH
THOSE OF THE FOUNDERS SUCH AS
HASTINGS. JUST A STUDENTS LEARN
ABOUT EUROPEAN ATROCITIES SUCH
AS THE HOLOCAUST. ALL STUDENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD ALSO LEARN ABOUT THE
GENOCIDE OF NATIVE AMERICANS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
. BUT THE FIRST STEP IS FOR
LOCAL SCHOOL TO CONNECT WITH
THEIR LOCAL TRIBES BECAUSE THAT
HISTORY AND CULTURE. IS NOT
ALWAYS INCLUDED IN THE TEXT
BOOKS IN THEIR LOCAL AREAS. BY
ENCOURAGING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
LOCAL AMERICAN INDIAN TASK FORCE
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL ALLEY ACE WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE DIALOGUE AROUND AND TO MOVE
FORWARD. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR
WAS MEANT TO START THATPROCESS.
AND NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE I WILL BE INTRODUCING
A NEW PIECE OF LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR AND WORKING WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO FURTHER
THAT MISSION THAT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR- STARTED WITH THAT
DIALOGUE AND MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE INSTRUCTION. OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST POPLE AND WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
BECAUSE OUR ARE WE AS A
COMMITTEE OR STATE SO NAIVE TO
THINK THAT OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YEARS OF MYTHOLOGY AND
FALSEHOODS CAN BE OR WILL BE
CORRECTED WITH ONE BILL. IT'S A
LONG TERM APPROACH BUT THE
BRIDGE BUT THE JOURNEY BEGINS
WITH ONE STEP AND TODAY WITH THE
INTENT OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION STARTING THE
DIALOGUE AND THE INTENT TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. SERVES
AS THAT MECHANISM IN THIS THE
DREAM OF THE CALIFORNIA OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE WOULD
BE TO SEE THE HISTORY. OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE TAUGHT
TO BOTH NATIVE AMERICAN AND NON
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS ALIKE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INSTILLING PRIDE IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS AND TO FURTHER
UNDERSTANDING AND THE NON NATIVE
KIDS ABOUT THE TRUE AND FACTUAL
HISTORY. GOOD AND BAD HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ORIGINALLY HAD TESTIMONY FROM C.
T. A REPRESENTATIVE MERRY LEVI.
AND CHAIRMAN GREG SARRIS. IN
THOSE TESTIMONIES THAT WE'RE
LOOKING HERE TODAY- CHAIRMAN
GREG SARRIS TESTIMONY WILL BE
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA TO READ THAT AND
TO THE HISTORY AND INTO THE
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU PERHAPS A
MEMBER RAMOS- MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GIVEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT- DID NOT
ALLOW FOR TESTIMONY TO BE DONE-
VIRTUALLY. WAS TAPPED UP BY
CHAIRMAN GREG SARS OF FEDERATED
INDIANS OF GRATON RANCHERIA TO
READ HIS STATEMENT. AND READ
THIS FOLLOWS GROWING UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I WAS TAUGHT
THE USUAL RHETORIC IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE. WE
BUILT MISSIONS OUT OF SUGAR
CUBES AND POPSICLE STICKS AND
UNDERSTOOD THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES ACCORDING TO WHITEWASH
HISTORY PROPAGATED BY POPULAR
CULTURE AND THE CHAPTER TWO IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEXTBOOKS. THAT
WAS FIFTY PLUS YEARS AGO THE
CURRENT INSTRUCTIONAL CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN SOCIAL SCIENCE
STANDARDS AND FRAMEWORKS HAVE AN
IMPROVEMENT SINCE. AND DO NOT
TELL HE TO NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE STORY. WHEN I WAS A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR ASKED ME.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE I'VE NEVER
SEEN PEOPLE LIKE BEES. HE WAS
REFERRING TO THE CHARACTERS IN
THE STORY THAT WOULD BECOME A
NOVEL ENTITLED GRAND AVENUE
ABOUT A FAMILY OF CALIFORNIA
INDIANS. EVEN IN AN URBAN
NEIGHBORHOOD. LATER WHILE
WORKING ON SCREEN PLAY FOR AN H.
B. O. MINI SERIES OF THE SAME
NAME. A MENTOR AT SUNDANCE
COMMENTED. I DON'T KNOW AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND INDIANS
INTERACTIVE. AS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IT IS
TIME TO TEACH THE REAL HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIANS OF AMERICANS.
THE PROPOSED CALIFORNIA. INDIAN
EDUCATION ACT WOULD REQUIRE AND
PROVIDE SOCIAL STUDIES
CURRICULUM FOR GRADES THREE FOUR
EIGHT AND ELEVEN. ABOUT
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CULTURE WE MUST
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GRANTED MUCH
OF THE HISTORY IS DIFFICULT THE
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
AND ROLLED MEMBERS OF MY TRIBE
FEDERATED INDIANS OF GRATON
RANCHERIA DESCEND FROM FOURTEEN
SURVIVORS OF A COMBINED COASTAL
TRIED ME WALK AND SOUTHERN
FORMAL PRE EUROPEAN CONTACT
POPULATION. APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. THE HORRORS OF
EUROPEAN DISEASE FOR WHICH WE
HAD NO IMMUNITY AND SLAVERY
UNDER THE SPANISH MEXICAN. AND
AMERICAN PERIODS TOOK ITS TOLL.
THIS HISTORY SHOULD NOT BE
TAUGHT TO SHAME BUT THE HEEL AND
TO LEARN. TO LEARN IN AN
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE WORLD WAYS
NOT TO REPEAT THE PAST BUT TO
NEGOTIATE A POSITIVE BREAK
RELATIONSHIP WITH PEOPLE
DIFFERENT FROM OURSELVES.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN EDUCATION ACT
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR STATE AS A LEADER IN NATIVE
AMERICAN ISSUES. THERE ARE
ALWAYS HAS BEEN AND STILL IS A
LARGER INDIGENOUS POPULATION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE HUNDRED FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND OKAY LOS
ANGELES ARE HOME TO THE COUNTY'S
LARGEST URBAN INDIAN POPULATIONS
. YET UNTIL RECENTLY NO ONE
SEEMS TO KNOW WE ARE HERE. AS ILIKE TO SAY UNTIL THERE WERE
CASINOS NO ONE KNEW WE SURVIVED
THE MISSIONS. CALIFORNIANS CAN
CHANGE THAT. PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ACTUALLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
GARCIA DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS YEAH SO- WE ALSO HAVE-
REPRESENTING CTA MERRY LEVI-
TESTIMONY HERE IN PERSON TO BE
READ BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK SILVA. OKAY AND THAT OULD
TAKE CARE OF OUR TO WITNESS YOU
COME UP TO THE TABLE BY THE WAY
I MEAN. JUST YEAH. HELLO HEARING
SYSTEM. HELLO CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MERRY
LEVI AND I AM HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CTA WE APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD ON
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
CURRICULUM AND STUDENT ACCESS.
MERRY CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE
CHAIR OF CTAS AMERICAN INDIAN
ALASKA NATIVE CAUCUS AND IS AN
ELECTIVE REPRESENTATIVE TO CTAS
POLICY MAKING STATE COUNCIL OF
EDUCATION. CTA'S ORGANIZATIONAL
POLICY STRONGLY SUPPORTS OF
TEACHING STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
ANCESTRAL LEGACIES IN THE
CULTURE OF ARE CALIFORNIA
NATIVES PEOPLE. WE FEEL THAT
THIS IS A CENTRAL IN THE
STRUGGLE FOR RACIAL RACIAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY. CTA SUPPORTS
PROMOTING GENUINE RESPECT FOR
INDIVIDUAL AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY BY PROVIDING STUDENTS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A WELL
ROUNDED EDUCATION THAT INCLUDES
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND OUR NATIVE
PEOPLE CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE SHOWN THIS
THROUGH THE SUPPORT OF OUR BILLS
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER LOANS BILL
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH CALLED
FOR A MODEL CURRICULUM FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES BUT WAS
NOT FUNDED AND AB ONE SIXTY
THREE WILLIAMS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
TO ALLOW AUTHORIZED ELDERS TO
RECEIVE A TEACHING CREDENTIAL TO
TEACH THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE. AND AB NINE FORTY FIVE
RAMOS ALLOWING NATIVE STUDENTS
TO WEAR THEIR TRIBAL REGALIA
DURING THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. MOST RECENTLY WE
FOUGHT FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
INCLUDING NATIVE AMERICAN
CURRICULUM WHICH ENHANCES
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND IS A
CENTRAL COMPONENT OF A
CULTURALLY DIVERSE EDUCATION.
HOWEVER EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
PROVIDED SUPPORT WE CONTINUE TO
FIND. NEEDING TO HAVE ACCESS TO
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND
CURRICULUM TO RESENT TO THEIR
STUDENTS THESE ARE SMALL STEPS
TO ACHIEVING A LARGER GOAL.
TEACHERS FACE MANY CHALLENGES IN
FINDING ADEQUATE CURRICULUM
RESOURCES ON THIS ISSUE FOR
ELEMENTARY GRADES WE NEED TO
TEACH ABOUT OUR LOCAL NATIVE
COMMUNITIES. BUT THERE IS QUITE
A LONG LETTER SO I'M GOING TO
KIND OF WRAP UP BUT I THINK. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IS THE
CENTRAL AS WE KNOW US FELLOW
EDUCATORS IS MAKING SURE THAT
CURRICULUM IS NOT ONLY ACCURATE
IT'S FACTUAL AND THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
NEED TO RECEIVE THAT AND THIS IS
ON BEHALF OF. MERRY SORRY LEAVE
A- WHERE THIRTY MERRY FROM CTA
GOT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH
FOR THE PRESENTATION I WILL NOT
GO TO THE PUBLIC SO IF YOU'RE A
MANTA MEMBER THE PUBLIC AND YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT WELL YOU CAN
USUALLY WALK UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME IF
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION SAY THAT AND
WHETHER AND THAT YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT'S NOT A
TIME FOR FURTHER TESTIMONY IT'S
JUST TIME TO KIND OF SAY HERE'S
WHO I AM. HERE'S MY REPRESENT
AND HERE'S MY POSITION ON THE
BILL SEE ME WALK UP TO THE
MICROPHONE NOW I THINK WE NEED
TO SPACE OUT A LITTLE BIT AND-
SHARE YOUR YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. PLEASE ONLY. GOOD
AFTERNOON JULIE AT MY ESTAS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COLLEGE
AND I SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
FOUR IN THE INITIATIVES OF THE
DISCUSSION THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT
PERSON OH WAIT A MOMENT I'M
SORRY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NEED IS
A MAILING THING. FROM MY VOICE
AND I AM IN SUPPORT WITH THE
BILL LET'S TALK ABOUT TODAY.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JEANNIE MENDOZA I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COLLEGE
AND I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT WITH THE
BILL- SPOKE ABOUT TODAY. WELL
DONE THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF OF
THE MORONGO BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRANK MOLINA ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN MANUEL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS AND THE SENATE
IS SPANISH YOU MENTIONED IN SOME
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOMS ANYONE
OPPOSE THE BILL- SEEING
OPPOSITION- DO ANY. THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE A VOTE ON THE SO NO
NO MOTION NECESSARY. BUT ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY AND
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
BENNETT. JUST LIKE I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK BACK TO MY
TWENTY TWO YEARS TEACHING. AND
HOW VALUABLE WOULD HAVE BEEN HAD
I AND OTHERS TAPPED INTO THE
LOCAL TRIBES. TO HELP MAKE THIS
CONNECTION THAT- YOU'RE SO
IMPORTANTLY POINTING OUT O US
NELSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CUSHION THANK YOU MR OF ABOUT
IT. AND ALL THIS YEAR REALLY THE
SAME OPINION- AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER I THINK IT'S ALL ABOUT
RESOURCES RIGHT WHERE DO I GO TO
LEARN ABOUT THE LOCAL TRIBES AND
I KNOW THAT. YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
CREATING SOME TYPE OF RESOURCE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE THERE'S
DIFFERENT TRIBES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REALLY WANT
TO LEARN ABOUT THE LOCAL ONES
YOU'VE- EITHER GOT TO GO TO A
LOCAL TRIBE OR MAKE SOME
CONNECTION AND IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF WE HAD SOME. CLEARING HOUSE
IF YOU WILL- WHERE WE CAN HAVE
THAT INFORMATION- ACCESSIBLE TO
TEACHERS. RIGHT SO THEY CAN
SHARE THE STORY IN A MORE
ACCURATE WAY. SO ON THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING I KNOW I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH MISTER BENNETT I
DON'T SEE ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
SO WITH THAT ARE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENTS- SO MEMBER BENNETT
AND THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS A
MAN- AB FIFTY FIFTY FOUR IS A
MEANT TO MOVE FOR WITH THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
START TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
AND IT'S BEEN OVER A HUNDRED
SEVENTY YEARS OF A LACK OF
FACTUAL HISTORY AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD AS A BODY AND AS
A STATE AS A COMMITTEE TO START
TO FULFILL THAT MISSION. IT'S A
ROAD THAT THE TAKES THE FIRST
STEP IN AND AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THANK YOU FOR BEING
ABLE TO PRESENT THIS AND HAVE
THE TESTIMONY READ HERE. BY SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES THAT ALSO
SHOWS THE IMPORTANCE TO THE
LEGISLATURE OF HOW IMPORTANT
THIS ISSUE IS A BUILDING THAT
RELATIONSHIP. AND WE ARE WORKING
ON A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE INTEND ON INTRODUCING- PRETTY
QUICKLY. I'M TO START TO IT S.
ON THE ISSUES OF LOCAL
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING WITH LOCAL. AMERICAN INDIAN TRIBES AND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
THE USED TO BUILD THAT
CURRICULUM THAT THAT COULD FEED
ON TO THE STATE- AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WE'RE WORKING WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM STATE
SUPERINTENDENT INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND WHO IS. TOTALLY IN
FAVOR OF THESE TOPICS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY. SO ON
A THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS THIS ISSUE. AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND TO
CONTINUE. TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
VOICES OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE IS NOT ONLY HEARD IN THE
NEWSPAPERS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT UP
AS BUT HEARD IN THE CLASSROOMS.
IN STARTING EARLY TO EDUCATE ALL
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
VISITING THE BILL AND LOOK FOR
TO MORE DISCUSSIONS AS WE HEAD
INTO THE NEW YEAR. AND AGAIN.
JUST FROM A CLASSROOM
ERSPECTIVE RESOURCES RESOURCES
RESOURCES THOSE THAT'S WHERE IT
STARTS. BECAUSE WITHOUT THOSE.
RIGHT WHERE TEACHERS GO. HEY
GOOD FOR THEM KNOW THAT BEGINS
WITH THE ROLE THAT BRIDGE WHEN
THE CLASSROOM TEACHER IN THE
LOCAL TRIBES OF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I CAN HEAR TRUE
CHAMPION. WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO MISTER
SALAS. WHEN WE GO AND- SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH WARM. O'DONNELL HERE.
ARE DONALD PRESENT BENNETT.
SENATE PRESIDENT CHEN. CHOI HERE
. CHOI PRESENTLY LEE PRESENT
MCCARTY. MCCARTY PRESENT CORK
SILVA. WORKS OF THE PRESENT WE
HAVE ACQUIRED WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM I MISTER SALAS YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- THANKS COMMITTEE MEMBERS A
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY EIGHT ON YOUTH
SUICIDE PREVENTION FIRST LET ME
BEGIN BY STATING I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN. AND YOUR STAFF- FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AB FIFTY EIGHT
WILL IMPROVE YOUTH SUICIDE AND
SELF HARM PREVENTION BY ENSURING
THAT THE BEST PRACTICES AND
MODEL POLICY FOR SUICIDE
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION
IDENTIFIED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE
BEING UTILIZED BY OUR LOCAL
EDUCATION. AGENCIES ARE ELLIE AS
YOU SUICIDE AND SELF HARM IF
CONTINUED TO RISE ALARMINGLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA THE RATE
OF SUICIDE AMONG THOSE AGE TEN
TO TWENTY FOUR INCREASED 38%
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
AT TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
ACCORDING TO A REPORT RELEASED
BY CDC IN TWENTY TWENTY. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE UNITED
HEALTH FOUNDATION REPORT FOUND
THAT THE TEEN SUICIDE RATE
INCREASED BY 25% NATIONWIDE.
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
ONE OF SEVEN STATES. WITH THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
TEEN SUICIDE RATES DURING THAT
TIME. AND HAS A TEMPER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE STATE AUDITOR OUR
STATE AUDITOR RELEASED A REPORT
TITLED YOUTH SUICIDE PREVENTION-
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES LACK
THE RESOURCES AND POLICIES.
NECESSARY TO EFFICIENTLY. TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS RISING RATES
OF YOUTH SUICIDE AND SELF HARM-
AMONG THE FINDINGS OF THE
ATTITUDES OF THE ELEAZAR.
ELEAZAR WERE YOU HAD NOT HAD IT.
HAD NOT ADOPTED ADEQUATE YOUTH
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES AND
TRAINING. I'VE JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE- THANK YOU DO
YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL I THINK WE HAVE ONE THAT'S-
ARE YOU ALLOWING A PHONE
TESTIMONY THIS COMMITTEE. WE ARE
NOT THEM I DON'T BELIEVE THEY'RE
HERE IN PERSON HE SAID THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- ANY ANY
ANY PERSONS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL PRESENT- SEEING NO
OPPOSITION- WE WILL- GO TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
BILL. IT'S BEEN MOVED MOVED BY
MISTER BENNETT. SECONDED BY
MISTER MY MISTER LEE. OKAY WHAT
WELL WITH THAT- I JUST WANT
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL YOUR
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS AN ONGOING
SOCIETAL PROBLEM- VERY NECESSARY
AND VERY TRAGIC RIGHT TOO OFTEN
SO I THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT
AND IT IS REAL IN OUR SCHOOLS
TODAY. AND KOVARIK CETERA WE ALL
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE
EVEN ABSENT COVERT TODAY'S HIGH
SCHOOL EXPERIENCE MIDDLE SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE IS CHALLENGING SO I
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU- MISTER SALAS. AND YOU MAY
CLOSE. THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE AND SWAN SAY THERE IS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THERE'S NOT
PRESENT. I'M SORRY THERE IS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THEY'RE
JUST NOT PRESENT ON THIS OKAY
NOW AND I'M I'M I'M QUITE
CONFIDENT OF THAT THANK YOU. SO
WITH THAT- SECRETARY ARE YOU DO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS RIGHT.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DONALD. I ARE DONALD AYE
BENNETT. AYE CHAN. CHOI CHOI I
BELIEVE LEE I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE CORK SILVA. WORKS OF ART
THANK YOU. THE BILL HAS EXPIRED
THE BILL HAS EXPLODED IS OUT MR
SAUCE WHEN I GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. I BELIEVE THIS RACE
IS PRESENTING PERMITS FRIEDMAN
MISS FRIEDMAN IS NOT WITH US
TODAY I'M- SIR YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READING. HERE ARE THE
NUMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
FOUR FIFTY TWO ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WHO WANTS TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YOUR COMMITTEE
STUFF FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL ESPECIALLY OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS. AB FOUR FIFTY
TWO WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO DEVELOP AN UPDATE
AS NECESSARY A NOTIFICATION.
REGARDING SAFE FIREARM STORAGE
THAT WILL BE ANNUALLY. PROVIDED
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR DISTRIBUTION.
SPECIFICALLY THIS NOTIFICATION
WILL INFORM PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS OF THE CALIFORNIA.
CHILD ACCESS PREVENTION LAWS AND
LAWS RELATING TO THE SAFE
STORAGE OF FIREARMS. AWARENESS
OF THESE LAWS HELPS TO PREVENT
TRAGEDIES DUE TO UNINTENTIONAL
DISCHARGES SUICIDES AND GUN
THEFTS BY CRITICS CREATING AN
ENVIRONMENT HELPING TO ENSURE
FIREARMS ARE ONLY USED BY THEIR
RIGHTFUL OWNER. NEW DATA
RELEASED BY THE CDC SHOWS THAT
FIREARMS WERE THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR CHILDREN AND TEENS
IN AMERICA IN TWENTY TWENTY.
EVERY YEAR EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND TEENS ARE SHOT AND
KILLED OR WOUNDED AND
APPROXIMATELY THREE MILLION ARE
EXPOSED TO GUN VIOLENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
EXACERBATED THIS PROBLEM IT IS
TIME TO ENSURE FIREARMS ARE
SAFELY STORED AWAY FROM CHILDREN
TEENS AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON OUR REBEKAH MARCUS
FROM BRADY AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
AND EMILY SCHWARTZ FROM. WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE. HELLO YOU
COME TO THE TABLE UP HERE. I
TESTIFIED AND THEN WHEN YOUR
DONE THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT
MAY COME UP. THANK YOU TWO
MINUTES MAX PLEASE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
REBEKAH MARCUS REPRESENTING THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN BRADY HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME ADVOCATE FOR SAFE
STORAGE ACCESS PREVENTION LAWS
THESE LAWS PROMOTE RESPONSIBLE
GUN OWNING PRACTICES BY
REQUIRING GUN OWNERS TO KEEP
THEIR FIREARMS OUT OF THE REACH
OF OTHERS. WHO COULD USE THE
WEAPON TO DEADLY EFFECT THESE
LAWS PREVENT FAMILY FIRE A
SHOOTING INVOLVING AND PROPERLY
STORED OR MISUSED GUN FOUND IN
THE HOME RESULTING IN INJURY OR
DEATH CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE STANDARDS FOR
SAFETY DEVICES. AND PROHIBITS
ANY PERSON FROM COMMERCIALLY
SELLING ANY FIREARM SAFETY
DEVICE THAT IS NOT LISTED ON THE
STATE'S ROSTER THESE LAWS SAVE
LIVES PREVENT TRAGEDIES DUE TO
UNINTENTIONAL DISCHARGES SUICIDE
AND GUN THEFT BY ENSURING THAT
FIREARMS CAN ONLY BE ACCESSED
AND USED BY THEIR RIGHTFUL
OWNERS. PASSING COMPREHENSIVE
STANDARDS FOR SAFETY DEVICES AND
STORAGE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
HOWEVER WERE MISSING A CRUCIAL
STEP WHEN WE DON'T TAKE THE TIME
TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND IN
PARTICULAR PARENTS ABOUT THESE
LIFESAVING LOS PROXIMITY TO
UNSECURED FIREARMS HAS PLAYED A
KEY ROLE DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC MARKETS WERE
GENERALLY BEING KEPT HOME. AND
DURING A PERIOD OF RECORD NEW
GUN OWNERSHIP THE NUMBER OF
UNINTENTIONAL SHOOTINGS
INVOLVING CHILDREN ROSE BY
THIRTY ONE PERCENT. OVER 75% OF
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ARE FACILITATED
BY KIDS WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
UNSECURED AND OR UNSUPERVISED
GUNS AT HOME KEEPING GUNS LOCKED
AND UNLOADED REDUCES THE RISK OF
DEATH FROM UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS AND SUICIDE. AMONG
YOUTH BY 73% WHICH IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE 70% OF CHILDREN AND UN
OWNING A HOUSE HOUSEHOLDS KNOW
WHERE THE FIRE ARMS ARE CAPPED
SADLY OVER 80% OF TEENS WHO
COMMIT SUICIDE WITH THE GUN USED
ONE THAT BELONG TO SOMEONE IN
THEIR HOME. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT SAFETY SAFELY STORING
FIREARMS BECOMES THE CULTURAL
NORM LIKE PUTTING ON A SEATBELT
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
CAN DO IS TO EDUCATE PEOPLE FROM
ALL THAT FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE URGE AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WITNESS ME
ONE MOMENT I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREATS FOR
INTRODUCTION AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIFTY TELL MY
NAME'S EMILY SCHWARTZ AND I'M A
YOUTH ADVOCATE FOR GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION I'M HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND OVER
THE SIX HUNDRED CONSTITUENTS WHO
SIGNED A LETTER IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR FIFTY TO. A LETTER I HOPE
YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO READ OR
HAVE BEFORE YOU. I'M NOT ONLY A
YOUTH ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN AGAINST
GUN VIOLENCE IN SAFE GUN STORAGE
LETTERS LEGISLATION AND LAWS.
I'M ONE OF THE ALMOST TWO
MILLION HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO GO TO SCHOOL EACH
DAY AFRAID. WHEN I WALK INTO
MATH CLASS I DON'T THINK ABOUT
HOW TO SOLVE FOR X. I THINK
ABOUT WHERE I WILL HIDE AND
WEARABLE RUN IN CASE OF AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER. ACCORDING TO
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY. FENCE
USED IN 68% OF GUNS RELATED.
INCIDENTS AT SCHOOLS WERE TAKEN
FROM THE HOME OF. OR RELATIVE.
AND THIRTY NINE PER OF PARA
WRONG BELIEVE CHILDREN DON'T
KNOW WHERE THE GUN IS STILL. AN
ESTIMATED OF FOUR PER SIX. A
CHILDREN LIVING HOME AT LEAST
ONE GUN IS. LOADED AND I'M- I
HAVE A FRIEND WHO ATTENDS AUGUST
HIGH SCHOOL. HE WATCHES CLASS
MIGHT TAKE THEIR FINAL BREATHS
ON THE DAY OF THE SHOOTING. I'VE
SEEN THE TRAUMA THAT HAS FORMED
SINCE THAT DAY. I WITNESSED
FRIENDS FALL INTO PANIC FROM THE
NOISE OF A HELICOPTER I'VE SEEN
THEM FRIED AND FROM THE SOUND OF
AN ALARM. I WATCHED THE CHILD
INSIDE THEM DISAPPEAR. WE NEED
MEANINGFUL MULTIFACETED ACTION
TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS SAFE ACTIONS
THAT ADDRESS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS. WE NEED ACTION
THAT WILL PREVENT SHOOTINGS FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS SOME OF
THE STRONGEST SAFE GUN STORAGE
AND CHILD ACCESS PREVENTION LAWS
IN THE COUNTRY. NOW TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT EVERY PARENT CARE
GIVER. OF A CALIFORNIA STUDENT
KNOWS THOSE LAWS. AB FOUR FIFTY
TWO WILL DO JUST THAT AND AS
PART OF THE APPROACH THAT WILL
HELP KEEP ME AND MY FRIEND SAFE.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS CRITICAL
LIFESAVING LEGISLATION I THINK
IN ADVANCE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY WELL
PRESENTED VERY WELL DONE. THE
JOB- WITH THAT- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR ANY OTHER
PERSONS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL. SONORA IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL. SAYING
NO OPPOSITION WE WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY CONTRARY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SINGLE COMMA
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. THIS WAS SECONDED BY-
MOVED BY MISTER LIU MCCARTY WAS
SECOND BY MR LEAVE- PLEASE CLOSE
IT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THEIR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS. OF THE SECULAR CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB FOUR FIFTY TO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DONALD HI DONAL I
BENNETT. BENNETT AYE CHAN. CHOI
CHOI I LEE THE AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE CORK SILVA QUICK
SILVA HI THANKYOU. LOS ALAMOS
THE BILL HAS EXPLODED AS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR STEPPING
AND- WITH THAT WILL GO TO- ARE
WE NEED TO CLARIFY A PREVIOUS
MOTION. OKAY OKAY I WILL GO TO A
FILE NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE EIGHT FIVE NINE OR SIX.
WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LET ME KNOW
WHEN YOU WHEN I SHOULD START.
FIVE CORRECT. THANK YOU FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE SEARCHER THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WONDERFUL WORK OF
YOUR STAFF VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
HOW DILIGENTLY THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ME OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST YEAR YEAR AND A HALF
IN ORDER TO BRING THIS BILL TO
THE TO THE TO WHERE IT IS TODAY.
IN GENERAL OVERVIEW AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENTS
AND GRANT MONEY TO SCHOOLS TO
INCENTIVIZE THE ADOPTION OF
PLANT BASED VEGETARIAN AND
RESTRICTED. DIET MEALS AND PLANT
BASED MILK OPTIONS. ALSO IT WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ON HOW TO SERVE
ELIGIBLE YOUNGER SIBLINGS. A
FEDERALLY REIMBURSABLE MEAL. AT
A SCHOOL SITE. THAT THEIR
SIBLINGS ATTENDS THAT THEIR
SIBLING ATTENDS. WE HAVE TAKEN
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS IN ORDER TO
MAKE THE BILL AS INCLUSIVE AS
POSSIBLE OF THOSE WITH SPECIAL
DIETARY NEEDS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING. THE CORE GOALS OF
THE BILL. WITHIN OUR AMENDMENTS
WE HAVE ADDED. TO OTHER DIED
OPTIONS RESTRICTED FOOD OPTIONS
WHICH ARE- BASICALLY KOSHER
HALAL WHICH IS INCLUSIVE OF ALL
TYPES OF MEAT AS WELL- INVADES
AND VEGETARIAN FOOD OPTION. AT
THIS AT ITS CORE THE BILL SEEKS
TO BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION FOR
TWO CRITICAL ISSUES. REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND IMPROVING
CHILDHOOD NUTRITION. A PILOT
ANALYSIS OF OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT CONDUCTED BY
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH DOCUMENTED
A 14% REDUCTION IN CARBON
EMISSIONS AND A 6% REDUCTION IN
WATER USE. AS A RESULT OF
IMPLEMENTING THE GOALS OF THIS
BILL. PLANT BASED FOODS HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH BENEFITS AS
WELL THESE INCLUDE REDUCING THE
RISK OF DIABETES CANCER AND
HELPING TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
WEIGHT. BY GIVING KIDS THE
OPTION OF HEALTHIER DIVERSE MEAL
OPTIONS WE ARE HELPING THEIR
DEVELOPMENT AT AN EARLY AGE.
SIMILARLY BY ASSISTING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO REACH
ELIGIBLE NON SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
TO RECEIVE FREE OR REDUCED PRICE
BREAKFAST. THE BILL WILL GIVE
OPPORTUNITY TO MANY KIDS TO
RECEIVE MAILS THEY OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE. WITH THAT IN MIND
THIS BILL WILL TAP INTO THE
REACH AND EXPERTISE OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND REQUIRED THAT IT
ISSUE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN PROBABLY PROPERLY.
ADDRESS THE HUNGER NEEDS OF
YOUNGER CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT YET
OF SCHOOL AGE SO THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD SPECIFICALLY
BREAKFAST TO GUARANTEE THAT THEY
ARE FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT MEAL
OF THE DAY. DOING SO IS CRITICAL
FOR THE HEALTH OFSO MANY KIDS
IN THE SHORT TERM A CHILD
EXPERIENCING HUNGER IS LESS
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS IN
SCHOOL TO AVERT SCHOOL
DISCIPLINARY ACTION OR TO
PARTICIPATE IN EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES. IN THE LONG TERM
CHILDHOOD HUNGER INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE CHILD WILL
EXPERIENCE DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
COGNITIVE DEFICIENCIES AND ADULT
AUTO IMMUNE DISEASES THAT ARE
BOTH COSTLY AND PAINFUL AND
COLLEAGUES LET'S REMIND
OURSELVES COSTLY AT THE STATE
LEVEL STATE EXPENSE. ALL OF
THOSE COSTS ARE THEN ENCOURAGED
BY OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AND
MEDIC CAL ABSORBS IT. THE
OPPOSITION HAS ARGUED THAT- WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON FEEDING AS MANY
KIDS AS POSSIBLE RATHER THAN
DICTATING WHAT THEY EAT. BUT
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT AND
IT EXPANDS ACCESS TO MEALS FOR
KIDS BY REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ON SERVING ELIGIBLE
YOUNGER SIBLINGS OF FEDERALLY
REIMBURSABLE MEAL AT A SCHOOL
SIDE THAT THEIR SIBLING ATTENDS
MORE KIDS WILL NOW BE RECEIVING
MEALS. MORE IMPORTANTLY WE ARE
ALREADY TACKLING THIS PROBLEM OF
ACCESS WITH SENATOR SKINNER'S
UNIVERSAL MEAL DEAL WHICH
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSES THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERN THIS BILL
GOES HAND IN HAND WITH SENATOR
SKINNER'S BY FOCUSING. ON
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF FOOD WE
FEED OUR CHILDREN- THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE FOR THE CHILD
NUTRITION ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND TODAY WITH ME IS OUR
WITNESSES ARE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND- HERBIE WHO
REPRESENTS OUR BILL SPONSORED
PHYSICIAN COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE. AND
NICHOLAS SACKETT WHO REPRESENTS
OUR OTHER BILL SPONSORED SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU YOUR FIRST
WITNESS MAY COME UP TO THE TABLE
TO TESTIFY. TWO MINUTES PLACE IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T. ON BEHALF OF
THE PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE THE
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WITH OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY O TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS DOCTOR AND
HERBIE AND I'M A PHYSICIAN
COMMITTEES NUTRITION EDUCATION
PROGRAM MANAGER BASED IN WILLITS
CALIFORNIA. I'M A REGISTERED
DIETITIAN. AND CERTIFIED
DIABETES EDUCATOR WITH A
DOCTORATE IN HEALTH SCIENCES.
THE PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS THE CHILD NUTRITION ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS
LEGISLATION WILL INCENTIVIZE
EXPAND ACCESS TO PLANT BASED%
MEALS AND MILK OPTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
DOING SO THIS BILL WHEN WILL
INVEST IN THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN TODAY AND
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE HEALTHCARE
COSTS WELL INTO THE FUTURE.
THERE'S A CLEAR PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSENSUS ON THE NEED TO REDUCE
THE CONSUMPTION OF ANIMAL
PRODUCTS IN FAVOR OF MORE PLANT
BASED FOOD. PLANT PLANT BASED
DIETS HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
PREVENT AND REVERSE HEART
DISEASE AND IMPROVE CHOLESTEROL.
THEY CAN ALSO PREVENT AND
REVERSE TYPE TWO DIABETES
OBESITY AND HYPERTENSION WHICH
ARE ALL CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO
SEVERE COPD CASES. FOR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HEALTHY
PLANT BASED MEALS CAN PROVIDE
THE NUTRITIOUS DIET THAT WILL
HELP THEM THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
DAY. THE CDC CITES EVIDENCE
SHOWING THAT STUDENTS WHOSE DIET
LACKS IMPORTANT NUTRIENTS LIKE
THOSE FOUND IN PLANT BASED
MEALS. HAVE LOWER GRADES AND
HIGHER RATES OF ABSENTEEISM AND
TARDINESS. ON A LARGER SCALE
UNHEALTHY DIETS ALSO PLACE AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS DIET AND LIFESTYLE
RELATED DISEASES. NOW ACCOUNT
FOR SEVEN IN TEN U. S. DEATHS.
NINETY PERCENT. OF OUR NATION'S
INTERNAL THREE POINT FIVE
TRILLION DOLLAR HEALTHCARE
EXPENSES ARE FOR PEOPLE WITH AT
LEAST ONE CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION. IT'S TIME TO TURN
THIS TREND AROUND BY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HEALTHY PLANT BASED
MEALS. IN CONCLUSION. THE
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE URGES THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AND ADVANCE
AB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO THIS VITAL ISSUE.
THANK YOU. ONE SECOND HERE FOR
OUR NEXT WITNESS ON. SHARE MY.
AUTHORS OF THE COMPASSION
HONESTLY- YEAH FIVE HUNDRED AND
MILLION SCHOOL LUNCHES EACH YEAR
THE POLICIES THAT THE STATE
IMPLEMENTS AROUND WHAT FOODS ARE
. HAS AN ENORMOUS IN NOT ON OUR
C. HEALTH BUT ALSO UNLESS
OBVIOUSLY AND EQUALLY ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. BY CREATING
INCENTIVES FOR SCHOOLS TO REDUCE
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF HALF A
BILLION MEALS. WE WILL SEE A
MASSIVE AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT IN
OUR STATE'S FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. WHAT TOTAL FOOD
PRODUCTION ACCOUNTS 425% OF THE
WORLD. GHG EMISSIONS. MEAT AND
DAIRY SPECIFICALLY ACCOUNT FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN POINT 5%
ACCORDING TO THE U. N.'S FOOD
AND AG ORGANIZATION. ANIMAL
PRODUCTS PRODUCED MULTIPLE TIMES
MORE GHG EMISSIONS PER KILOGRAM
OF FOOD COMPARED TO FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES WITH THE WORST
OFFENDER BEEF EMITTING UP TO
SIXTY TIMES MORE. AND EVEN
CHEESE PRODUCING UP TO TWENTY
ONE TIMES MORE GHGS. AS WE
SHOULD ALL BE AWARE BY NOW THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE I. P. C.
C. REPORT ON THE CLIMATE HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED. BY THE U. N.
SECRETARY GENERAL AS A CODE RED
FOR HUMANITY. IF THE WORLD IS TO
MEET ITS TARGET OF LIMITING
GLOBAL WARMING TO WELL BELOW TWO
DEGREES CELSIUS. A SIGNIFICANT
SHIFT AWAY FROM MEAT DAIRY IS
NECESSARY. YET DESPITE THESE
FACTS ARE FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS CONTINUE TO
INCENTIVIZE MEAT DAIRY PRODUCTS
IN OUR SCHOOLS WITH SUBSIDIES
AND FINANCIAL HANDOUTS TO THE
SAME INDUSTRY THAT IS INCREASING
OUR HEALTH THE HEALTH CARE COST.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL DESTRUCTION.
AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT IT'S A SMALL
STEP TO MITIGATE THE ANTIQUATED
HARMFUL BUT ENTRENCHED POLICIES
WHICH PRIORITIZE THE ANIMAL AG
INDUSTRY OVER THE HEALTH OF BOTH
OUR CHILDREN. AND OUR PLANET. ON
BEHALF OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
THOUSANDS OF SUPPORTERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL-
CHARGES OR ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL OTHERS IN THE ROOM
SUPPORT. SIX OTHERS. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. GREAT- YOU SEE NO
THERE'S A SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL- SEEING OPPOSITION
THE BILL WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- MISS CORK SILVA. OUR
FIRST IS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND ASKED TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BILL LIFE I FEEL THAT IT'S-
NOT ONLY A PRIORITY BUT IT WILL
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE IRAN A
COMPANION BILL A HANDFUL YEARS
YEAR AGO DURING CURRY'S SCHOOL
pDISTRICTS TO START TO POKE AGAIN
BECAUSE ONE OF OUR FACTORS THAT
WE KNOW WHAT SCHOOL NUTRITION IS
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MOVE FROM COOKING TO PROCESSED
FOOD. AND AS WE LOOK AT A REALLY
STARK NUMBERS PARTICULARLY FOR
LATINO COMMUNITY WHAT THEY'LL BE
CITY AND DIABETES THIS IS A HUGE
IMPACT I WORKED IN A SCHOOL
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO WHERE
WE- JUST TRIED TO EVEN
ENCOURAGING MALE VERSUS
CHOCOLATE MILK AND THAT WAS A
BIG ISSUE SO US NOW TALKING OF
PLANT BASED- IS NOT JUST A TREND
AS YOU KNOW IT IS A TREND BUT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT AS WAS
MENTIONED NOT ONLY CLIMATE BUT
REALLY BETTER OUTCOMES STARTING
AT A YOUNGER AGE FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND EVENTUALLY. ARE
ADULTS AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
SO MUCH AND YOU A JOIN AUTHORS
THANK YOU. SOMETIMES WE FORGET
ABOUT IT WITH THAT- MR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER UNDESERVEDLY
AND- ICAN UNDERSTAND YOUR
INTENT OF THE BILL TO- STOP OR
REDUCE ARE NOW HUNGRY CHILDREN-
ON UNDER SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
INTENT IS GOOD BUT UP I. WONDER
WHETHER THIS IS SO RIGHT
APPROACH WAR UNDER THE- VEHICLE
IS SO NEEDED THE FOR THAT
PURPOSE. AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND
THAT EVEN OUR STATE ALONE. HAS
SO NOT IT. FRESH ARE CALFRESH
PROGRAM FOR INDIGENT PEOPLE
OUGHT TO STOP BY THE FAMILY'S
HUNGER. IN ADDITION TO- FEDERAL
SCHOOL WATER METER PROGRAMS. AND
I WONDER. WITH THAT YOU HAVE
DONE THE STUDY THERE ARE TRULY-
UNTIL SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN GO
HUNGRY- IF CHAU. I WONDER
WHETHER THIS SYSTEM OUR BEST
APPROACH UNLESS SUPPOSED TO SO
THAT MEANS SO. THE PARENT COULD
GO HUNGRY AS WELL. R. ADULT A
MOTHER CAN COOK FOR HERSELF AND
NOT TO FEED THE CHILD AND THAT
THE MOTHER. OR FATHER HAS TO
DRIVE THE CHILD. ONE YOU ALL
OVER TO THE SUPPOSED TO FOR YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THE BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN TO FLEE THE CHART
TO FREE THE CHILD AT SCHOOL. TO
ME THIS IS A VERY IMPRACTICAL
WAY. RATHER THAN STRENGTHENING
AND MAKING SURE EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO BE. IMPROVED OR
ENHANCED SUCH AS A KIND OF FRESH
WAR VETERAN- IT PROGRAM SO.
RESPOND CAN YOU CAN YOU REPLY
I'M HAPPY TO DOCTOR CHOI AND I
WANT TO REPLY TO YOU AND
MULTIPLE VOICES. ONE AS A FELLOW
IMMIGRANT AS WELL BUT I'LL WAIT
FOR THAT ONE FIRST TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT STUDIES
ABOUT. MALNUTRITION OR LACK OF
UP OF FOOD OPPORTUNITIES AND
FOOD AND SECURITY I DON'T I
THINK THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT
HERE'S THIS ISSUE. MAYBE AD
NAUSEAM. YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AND THE NEEDS. OVER
40% OF OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING FROM EITHER LACK OF
FOOD OR LACK OF ENOUGH FOOD
ACCESS TO FOOD AND SECURITY IS
AND I THINK I'M DOWNPLAYING BY
SAYING ONLY FORTY PERCENT. SO
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT NEED THAT WE
HAVE AND I WELCOME YOU SIR TO
COME TO MY DISTRICT ANY DAY. SO
THAT I CAN TAKE YOU AROUND ON A
DAY WHEN. IT WAS- ON ON ANY DAY
OF THE SCHOOL DAY. WHERE SCHOOL
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE IN SESSION
BUT BECAUSE OF A LOCAL FIRE OR
BECAUSE OF SOME CIRCUMSTANCE ALL
SCHOOLS IN THE AREA WERE SHUT
DOWN. I WELCOME YOU TO SEE THE
LINES. THAT CONGREGATE OUTSIDE
OF EACH OF MY SCHOOLS. I DRIVE
AROUND IN THE MORNINGS I LOOK
FOR THESE THINGS I SEE IT- THERE
ARE LONG LINES BOTH INDIVIDUALS
STANDING AS WELL AS PEOPLE IN
THEIR CARS WAITING TO PICK UP
THAT THESE MEALS FOR THEIR KIDS.
AND I REPRESENT A RELATIVELY
AFFLUENT COMMUNITY BY THE WAY. I
COULD I REPRESENT THE
COMMUNITIES OF TO LOOK A LAKE
SHERMAN OAKS. VIDEO CITY VALLEY
VILLAGE I AND YOU CAN JUST SEE
IF THERE'S NEEDS IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE THIS WHERE THERE'S
AFFLUENCE. WHAT THE NEW LOOK
WHAT THE NEED IS AND OTHER AREAS
OF THE STATE THAT DON'T HAVE
THESE AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES SO
THAT'S ONE. THERE'S A GREAT NEED
IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED IT'S AND
MANY OF YOUR- DISCUSSION ITEMS
THAT YOU HAVE ON IT ON A VERY
REGULAR BASIS TO. YOU KNOW I
DON'T. WHILE I WELL WE AL
BENEFIT FROM MANY EXPERTS COMING
AND SPEAKING TO US ABOUT BILL
IDEAS AND DIFFERENT NEEDS THAT
ARE THERE ARE ASIDE FROM OUR
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
. I CONSTRUCTED THIS BILL ALSO
BASED ON MY OWN PERSONAL VIEW OF
WHAT I SAW THE NEEDS TO BE. I'VE
HAD A BENEFIT GROWING UP IN AN
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY FAMILY MY
MOTHER WOULD. ALWAYS MAKE IT A
PRIORITY TO MAKE HOME COOKED
MEALS AND I HAD THE BENEFIT OF
GROWING UP. HAVING A BALANCED
DIET BETWEEN SOME ITEMS OF YOU
KNOW A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MEAT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT VEGETABLES AND
A LOT OF FRUITS. I DON'T SEE
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THAT BALANCE
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. I DON'T I
AND NOW RAISING MY OWN THREE
KIDS I DON'T SEE MY WIFE AND I
HAVING THE LUXURY OF TIME TO
PREPARE MEALS EVERY TIME AND SO
WE NEED TO RELY ON. MEALS FROM
EITHER PURCHASING THEM FROM
OUTSIDE AND SO SOMETIMES IT GOES
AGAINST THE BALANCE THAT WE WANT
TO HALF ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT TO
MAKE IT AT A PRICE POINT THAT'S
AFFORDABLE. SO THERE'S MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT I'M TRYING
TO ADDRESS HERE WITH THIS ONE
BILL. GATES IT GOES TO THE FACT
THAT MANY PARENTS ARE.
STRUGGLING IT GOES TO THE POINT
OF FOOD ALSO BEING COSTLY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INFLATION
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE DEALING WITH
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
POTENTIAL FEW YEARS. AND GIVEN
ALSO HOW TO WHAT EXTENT WE SEE
HEALTH LONG TERM HEALTH IMPACTS
AND CONSEQUENCES BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT OUR
CHILDREN EAT AT A YOUNG AGE IT'S
CRITICAL. IT'S CRITICAL AND SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK THIS IS A
VERY MODEST APPROACH. AT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF ALSO THE BREAKFAST
PROGRAM FOR TOP FOUR FOUR
SIBLINGS THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED. UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BY THE WAY JUST
SO YOU KNOW SIR. SO THIS IS SUCH
A VERY MODEST APPROACH OF TRYING
TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
FACETS OF THIS ISSUE THAT YOU'RE
DRESSING. SO I DO HOPE THAT YOU
CONSIDER SUPPORTING THIS OKAY
THANK YOU FOR EXPLANATION I
EIGHT- TONE DISPUTE. THAT- IN
AMERICA THERE SHOULD BE A NORMAL
PERSON IT'S A CHILD OR DOG TO
SHOULD CALL HUNGRY SO OF
AFFLUENT COUNTRY YES WE ARE IS-
DISTRIBUTION IN OUR- IS TO BE A
MATTER- WHAT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT THE MECHANISM- THE
SYSTEM SO THAT WE HAVE AS I
MENTIONED. OF THERE MAY BE SOME
UP- BROKEN- WHICH IN THEIR- IF
WE CAN STRENGTHENING AND- I'LL
FIND OUT THE WAY TO MAKE IT TO
WORK ON MORE PERFECT WHAT IF-
THE AMOUNT IS- IN THE
INSUFFICIENT WE CANNOT PROVIDE
THE R. MORE DAUGHTERS HERE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE TWENTY
CENTS MORE PER MEAL I WONDER HOW
EVEN CHILDREN'S MEAL CAN BE
PREPARED TO FOUR TWENTIES TWENTY
SEC SIX TWENTY CENT INCREMENTAL
ADDITION. IT'S ADDITION NOT
GETTING COMMENT I GUESS YES
ADDITIONAL YES SO 20% FROM-
SENSE- UPON ME AND I JUST
UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT'S THAT THE
WITH THE COST OF THAT THEY CAN-
CLAIM FOR REIMBURSEMENT BUT AN
ENEMY THE COST DOESN'T AT THIS
TIME IS AND NOT THE FOCUS OF MY-
QUESTION I. WONDER WHAT THAT
THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO DELIVER
ARE UNDER SCHOOL AGE MEANS THAT
THE VERY YOUNG CHILDREN ALTHOUGH
RATHER SEE SOME OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS SO WE'LL GET THE-
SUFFICIENT FOOD OR MONEY- SINCE
WE DO PROVIDE IN OUR TRIBAL
PREVENT STOCK THE HUNGRY PEOPLE
. OF OUR NOT WITH THE VARIOUS-
METHOD SO A CAT FRESH'S SOMEONE
NINE ALL FOR AND OTHER FACTORS
MEAL PROGRAM S. AS SO EFFECTIVE
I MAIL ALSO A GERMAN CONSISTS OF
TENNIS IS ALL THIS IS A
WONDERFUL. CON BUT PLEASE SPEAK
TO THE BILL YEAH IF I CAN OFFICE
SUGGESTION DR YEAH THIS IS JUST
MY FINAL COMMENT IS THE HOW TO
READ THE PREFERRED LEADERS CHILD
THERE SHOULD BE TAKING CARE OF A
FAD THAT IN THE WARM OUR HOME
ENVIRONMENT RATHER THAN MYSELF I
THAT TAKING THE TIME TO SCHOOL
TO FEED I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH. TO THAT'S
WHAT I'M CONCERNED. AT THE
DOCTOR CHOI. YOU HAVE MY CELL
NUMBER. YOU KNOW OUR MY OFFICE
IS. AND YOU KNOW HOW HOUSE. I BE
UP. PLEASE TAKE IT OF IT I'M
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU
SHOULD THIS BE PASSED THE- I'M
STILL GONNA BE LOOKING AT FOR OF
ON THE- ONCE IT. ALSO PASSES
THE- COMMITTEE. YOU'RE ALWAYS TO
WORK THIS I A PLACE TO DEBATE
AND HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS. I
WELCOME YOU TO ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PERIODS IN
BETWEEN THE COMMITTEES AND THE
FLOOR VOTES SO- I'M I'M AT YOUR
DISPOSAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT-
LET'S BRING IT BACK- I JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS LOOK SCHOOLS
DON'T NEED ONE MORE BURDEN RIGHT
NOW. WE NEED THEM OPEN WE NEED
THEM SAFE IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
THIS TIME I WILL. CONCEIT IS NOT
A BURDEN BECAUSE IT ISN'T YOU'RE
INCENTIVIZING. SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS- I ALSO
THINK NONPROFIT SCHOOLS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF THE- SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM SHOULD TO WILL WE HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD
I'M ALSO- YOU KNOW. MAY GOD
BLESS THE TURKEY SANDWICH THAT'S
WHAT I WAS RAISED ON YOU KNOW.
CHOCOLATE MILK IS UNDER ATTACK
TODAY WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO-
BUT- I THINK WE DO NEED A BIT
MORE RESEARCH YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CHILDREN TO SAY HEY I'M A PLANT
BASED MEAL. IS BETTER THEN MAYBE
A PLANT BASED. AND DERRY MAIL
RIGHT WAS MEET- I PERSONALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN. ENOUGH RESEARCHERS
SAY THAT'S THE WAY TO GO I THINK
WE NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS THAT
BECAUSE CHILDREN NEED PROTEIN.
OKAY WE ARE CARNIVORES BY
NATURE. RIGHT AND I KNOW SOMEONE
TO CHANGE THAT MAYBE THAT'S A
GOOD THING THERE IS A BAD THING
BUT I ALSO THINK WE SHOULD JUST
ASSUME THAT. BECAUSE SOMETHING
IS A PLANT THERE ARE NOT
GREENHOUSE GASES ASSOCIATED WITH
IT BECAUSE THERE ARE TRACTORS
THERE IS FUEL FOR THAT TRANSIT
TRACTOR EXHAUST THERE IS WATER.
THERE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH
DELIVERING WATER THERE'S
FERTILIZER SO JUST ASSUME THAT
YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE
SOMETHING'S A PLANT. EIGHT IT'S
ZERO GREENHOUSE GASES IT'S GOOD
I AND IT MAY EVEN BE IN THE END
MORE INTENSIVE- THEN THE VENDOR
PRODUCTS I DON'T KNOW I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT I'M NOT I'M NOT AN
EXPERT ON THAT BUT I JUST
THAT'S- THAT'S SOMETHING TO
CONTEMPLATE AS WE HAVE THESE.
DISCUSSIONS SO WITH THAT I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN AND
I'VE WORKED WITH A COUPLE OF
AUTHORS TO PULL THIS TOGETHER.
SO KUDOS TO YOU FOR DOING THAT
AND- WITH THAT IS OUR MOTION.
MISTER MR LEE MOVES- SCORE OF
THE MOVES MR LEE SECONDS AND YOU
MAY CLOSE I WILL TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS AS A CLOSE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU THE ONLY THING I WOULD
ADD IS AS AS A CARNIVORE MYSELF
I JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO OFFER
A BALANCE MORE BALANCE THAT'S
ALL I NEED IS I MYSELF AM NOT A
VEGETARIAN OR VEGAN. I HE COULD
CONSUME MEAT AND I'M HAPPY TO
THIS IS JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR CHILDREN THAT MAY NOT HAVE
SOME OF THE- FUND KEEP.
OPPORTUNITIES AT HOME. A TIP TO
BE INTRODUCED TO. A VARIETY OF
MEALS. GREAT THANK YOU WITH THAT
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
O'DONNELL RIGHT DONAL I BENNETT
. BENNETT I CAN CHOI. CHOI NOT
VOTING LEAVE HIS FULLY AYE
MCCARTY. AND KIRK SILVA. MARK
SILVA I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES. AT THE TO THE BILLS OUT FOR
VOTE VISITORS ARE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU AGREE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO RUN ITS COURSE OF AB
FOUR ZERO EIGHT WAS QUICK SO
WHAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE MCKINNEY VENTO
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE ACT IS A
FEDERAL LAW CREATED TO
COORDINATE RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
ACT PROVIDES FEDERAL FUNDS TO
STATES TO IDENTIFY YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH NEEDED
SERVICES. LOCAL HOMELESS.
LIAISONS ARE TO PROVIDE AN ARRAY
OF SERVICES INCLUDING
IDENTIFYING YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND PROVIDING THEM
WITH EDUCATIONALLY. RELATED
RESOURCES. SUCH AS TUTORING
TRANSPORTATION SCHOOL SUPPLIES.
FOOD AND COUNSELING TO HELP THEM
WITH THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
HOWEVER AND TWENTY NINETEEN A
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDIT. YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
REPORTED THAT LOCAL EDUCATION.
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE NOT
IDENTIFIED. ADEQUATELY PROVIDING
SERVICES TO HOMELESS YOUTH. IN
FACT THE L. E. AS THAT WERE
VIEWED IN THE AUDIT NONE OF THEM
SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED STAFF TO
ENSURE THEY WERE AWARE OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD HELP THEM
IDENTIFY YOUTH WHO NEEDED
SERVICES. AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
IN THE CLASSROOM WE ARE THE
TEACHERS WHO ARE CLOSEST TO
FAMILIES NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
CONFERENCES WITH FAMILIES WE SEE
THEM AT- SCHOOL EVENTS AND WE
LEARNED MANY THINGS ABOUT THEIR
FAMILIES IN THIS PANDEMIC THERE
WAS QUITE A BIT OF TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE LOSS STUDENTS WHAT
HAPPENED TO STUDENTS THAT WERE-
IF YOU WANT TO SAY GONE MISSING.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT WE FIND
OUT THAT INFORMATION BY EITHER
BEING DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
STUDENTS IN A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE FAMILIES KNOCKING ON DOORS
BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT WE CAN DO
MORE- THIS BILL AB FOUR OH FOUR
ZERO EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE. ALLEY
A HOMELESS LIAISONS TO OFFER
TRAINING ON IDENTIFYING HOMELESS
YOUTH TO TEACHERS PARA
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER SCHOOL
STAFF WHO HAVE DAILY CONNECTIONS
WITH WITH STUDENTS SO THIS IS.
THE BRIDGE HERE MANY TIMES OUR
LIAISONS ARE HOUSED IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES MAYBE OFF SITE
THIS WOULD AGAIN NOT MANDATE NOT
REQUIRE BUT SIMPLY SAY WE HAVE A
TRAINING THAT YOUR TEACHERS. OR
PARA STAFF CAN BE INVOLVED WITH
AND ADDS UP MISTER O'DONNELL
KNOWS I TEACHERS OFTEN RECEIVED
ANNUAL TRAINING WHETHER IT'S
FROM THE LIBRARY LADY WHO COMES
IN THE NURSE THIS COULD BE ADDED
TO THAT MENU IF. THE SCHOOL SITE
USES IT UP WITH THAT I BELIEVE.
I HAVE SOME OF YOU HAVE KNOWN ME
TESTIFIED BEFORE. HOMELESS
STUDENTS- ARE NOT ONLY
INCREASING THEIR AT RISK WE WANT
TO DO EVERYTHING TO THAT WE CAN
TO NOT ONLY IDENTIFY THEM BUT
SUPPORT THEM. GREAT THANK HIM AS
QUICK SILVA YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY NO WITNESSES FOR THAT'S
THAT'S MY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SINGING A WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS FROM
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE
HAD A MOTION I BELIEVE EARLIER.
OKAY DO WE LET ME CLARIFY THAT
WE DID ON THE MOTION- MISTER LEE
MODE MOVING MISTER BENNETT
SECOND MISTER CHOI. THANK YOU
ALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR SERVER-
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
HOMELESSNESS- SITUATION AND
ALSO. CHILDREN COMING TO SCHOOL
WITHIN THE HOME SIDE'S NAME A
NOT THAT DIFFERENT TO YOU DON'T
YOU DON'T IMPACT THAT THEIR-
ECONOMIC ACHIEVEMENTS AS WELL
AS- MONNING INCENTIVES ETCETERA
. WHEN THE HOME IS SO UNSTABLE-
AND THEN ALSO I DO KNOW THAT THE
TEACHERS ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
ANY PHYSICAL ABUSE- ISSUES US
WITH A CELL BY LAW REQUIRED. NOW
ESTABLISHING- ON EXPLODED UP I
READ IT AS A PHOTO ID IS THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
TEACHER BUT SOMEBODY OUT OF TO
BE. DECIMATED AND TRAINED TO
IDENTIFY. HOMELESS SO- CHILDREN
. I WONDER. IF YOU WERE
APPOINTED AS SO- DO NAY- ALL YOU
ARE OFF THAT THE HOMELESS
CHILDREN WHAT KIND OF A TRAINING
WOULD YOU KEEP WHAT TO LOOK FOR-
SO THAT IS- MY QUESTION UNLESS-
PROBABLY THE CHILDREN MAY NOT.
THE IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES OF
WOMAN TARA RETESTED RESEND YOU
OUT COMPOSING THIS BILL NO THIRD
PARTY TO IDENTIFY AND TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT THE- AND-
WHEN I GREW UP. IN KOREA- WE HAD
A IN A TEACHER ASSIGNED TO THAT
THE WHOLE YEAR- HAD THE
PROGRAMMABLE VISITING- H. TIES
SO HOME- NOT FOR THESE PURPOSES
IN THE HOME THIS PURPOSE IS
TOUGH BUT JUST TO. GET
ACQUAINTED WITH THE HOME BACK
FROM THE WHOLE OF THE TIME JUST
DOING ANY CONCERNS THAT THE
PARENTS MAY RELATE ABOUT THE
CHILD TO THE TEACHER IN ORDER TO
GET A PARENT TEACHER
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. SO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT WAS A
PRETTY GOOD PROGRAM- I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE IN
THIS COUNTRY. TIME WISE OR
LEGALLY BUT- STUDENTS ARE
PRESENT AT SCHOOL WE ARE TRYING
TO FIND TABLE ALL HOME
BACKGROUND SO WHAT KIND OF
INDICATION SO- SHOULD RETRAIN
THE PERSON TO LOOK FOR. I THINK
THERE'S MULTIPLE WAYS I MEAN THE
FIRST THE FIRST STEP IN THIS
BILL WOULD BE THE- HOMELESS
LIAISON WORKING WITH A STAFF FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL TEACHER IF THEY
CHOOSE THAT TRAINING TO SHOW
THEM SOME- SIGNS THAT THEY MIGHT
LOOK FOR I MEAN IT REPETITIVE
ABSENCES. COMING TO- OUR
CLASSROOM MAYBE WITH NO SUPPLIES
COMING TO SCHOOL POSSIBLY WITH
US SCHOOL UNIFORM NOT LAUNDERED
THINGS LIKE THAT THE COULD BE
SIGNS BUT IT'S ALL VERY
SENSITIVE AND PERSONAL BUT WE
ALSO KNOW. THE BEST WAY TO MAKE
CHANGE IS FROM PERSON TO PERSON
AND SO IF AN EDUCATOR HAS MORE
INFORMATION OF EITHER RED FLAGS
TO NOTICE QUESTIONS TO POSSIBLY
ASK WITHIN REASON I THINK THOSE
WERE BE THE BEST OUTCOME. AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT- THE STUDY
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES DON'T
ALWAYS SELF IDENTIFY. BUT IT'S
ALSO TAKING SOME OF THE STIGMA
AWAY FROM THIS ISSUE SO THAT
THEY FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE SELF
IDENTIFYING- THAT THAT'S A ONE
OUR APPROACH A HOWEVER WE DO OF
SEE OUR PEOPLE LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND THE WITH THE
CHILDREN AROUND WE NEED TO A
LOCKED UP QUICKER TO LIVE- THE
TO IDENTIFY WHO THEY ARE WHICH
WAS THAT THEY GO TO YES AND ALSO
WORKING WITH COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERS WHETHER IT'S THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT WITH THE-
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT ON THE
STREETS SOMETIMES ENGAGING THESE
FAMILIES THEMSELVES WHETHER THEY
SEE THEM IN CARS WHERE THERE. I
MEAN I'LL JUST PERSONALLY SAY WE
WALK AROUND OUR BLOCK WE SAW A
MOTHER AND HER DAUGHTER ABOUT
SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
EVERY MORNING BRUSHING HER
DAUGHTER'S CHAIR HAIR RIGHT OUT
OF THE SCHOOL AND SO MY THOUGHT
WAS KIND OF WHY ARE THEY THERE
SO EARLY- WHY IS SHE DOING SOME
OF THESE BASIC THINGS YOU WOULD
DO AT HOME AND SO WE TALKED TO
THE PRINCIPAL AND THEY ACTUALLY
WENT OUT AND- TALK TO THOSE THE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEY SAID NO
THEY WEREN'T HOMELESS BUT THAT
THEY HAD TO GET TO SCHOOL
EXTREMELY EARLY- BECAUSE THE
FATHER HAS A JOB AND HAD TO DROP
HIM OFF THAT EARLY AND SHE
WANTED TO STAY WITH THEIR
DAUGHTER. SO THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF KIND OF WORKING IN
MULTIPLE AREAS TO TRY. TO DO THE
BEST WE CAN FOR THE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU BRING IT UP TO US ALL
OF HAPPY TO MAKE A MOTION. ANY
OTHER TWENTY MEMBERS WISHED
COMMA WE DO ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND MISTER CHOI
THANK YOU ARE YOU MAKE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FOUR AWAIT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I BENNETT.
SENATE AYE CHAN CHOI HI CHOI I
LEAN LEE I MCCARTY PORK SILVA HI
QUICK SILVA HI THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISS WORK SO. WE WANT TO. OKAY
YEAH CAN WE WILL TO CLARIFY-
CLARIFY THE MOTION FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND THE
BILL DOES HAVE SIX VOTES AGAIN.
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AN ANSWER FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. FIFTY EIGHT.
AND I'M GONNA PASSED THE GAVEL
NOW TO MR. THAT BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO PRESENT A BILL. WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE A VICE CHAIR.
EUROPE MISTER BENNETT RIGHT NOW
IT WOULD NOT A SWORN IN- READ IT
HERE FROM- MISTER DONALD
REGARDING AB DINO TO MR DOLLAR
READY FOR YOUR COMMENTS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB NINE OH TWO
ESTABLISHES AN ALTERNATIVE
DESIGN BUILD PILOT PROJECT FOR
THE RECRUITMENT OF SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS CONTRACTS.
THE JUDICIAL MASSIVE METHOD FOR
AWARDING CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
IS DESIGN BID BUILD. WHERE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FIRST HIRES AN
ARCHITECT TO DESIGN A SCHOOL AND
THEN GOES OUT TO BID FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT KIND OF TO
SUIT TWO STEP PROCESS. UNDER
DESIGN BUILD A SCHOOL DISTRICT
SEEKS BIDS FOR BOTH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION. HAVING AN
ARCHITECTURE ARCHITECT AND
CONTRACTOR WORK TOGETHER FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROJECT IS
MORE EFFICIENT AND HELPS PREVENT
PROBLEMS LATER ON IN THE PROCESS
. WHAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHAT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER AGENCIES
HAVE FOUND IS THAT SETTING UP
PRICE FOR THE CONTRACT BEFORE A
DESIGN HAS STARTED OR HAS BEEN
COMPLETED BECAUSE AS ONE OF TWO
PROBLEMS. EITHER THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OVER PAYS BECAUSE THE
CONSTRUCTION COST PROJECT BY THE
BIDDER IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
TRUE ACTUAL COST WHICH MAY BE A
FEW YEARS AFTER THE CONTRACT IS
AWARDED. FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ENDS UP WITH A FACILITY THAT
USES LOWER QUALITY MATERIAL. FOR
THAT. ORD ORD. MATERIAL THAT DID
THAT DOESNOT MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE SCHOOL SUCH AS FEWER
CLASSROOMS BECAUSE A CONTRACT
AMOUNT CANNOT BE CHANGED. AB
NINE OH TWO ALLOWS A LIMITED
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PILOT. THAT
ALLOWS A SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
AWARD AN INITIAL BID THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS. AND INSTEAD ALLOWS A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO RENEGOTIATE
WITH THE DESIGN BUILD TEAM ONCE
THERE'S A DESIGN. LAST YEAR
THROUGH A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES RECEIVED
AUTHORITY TO USE PROGRESSIVE
DESIGN BUILD. THIS BILL PROVIDES
VERY SIMILAR TO VERY SIMILAR
AUTHORIZATION TO DISTRICTS WITH
FIFTY THOUSAND OR MORE ADA AND
FOR LARGER PROJECTS SO IT'S
ABOUT ELEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE MORE LOSS. THE JANUARY
THIRD VERSION OF THIS BILL WAS
BASED ON SUGGESTIONS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION. I UNDERSTAND THEY
HAVE ADDITIONAL CONCERNS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. THOUGH
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS JUST CAME
ABOUT THE LAST COUPLE DAYS THIS
BILLS GOING TO PRINT FOR
SOMETIME. I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TO FURTHER CLARIFY
THAT THE PROCESS FOR AWARDING
SUBCONTRACTS CON SUBCONTRACTOR
CONTRACTS DOES NOT APPLY TO
THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE
DESIGN BUILD TEAM. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE LOS ANGELES%
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS DEBORAH
BAUTISTA'S OF OCT. IT HIS PARTY
STUFF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOUBLE DOUBLE THE SIZE
OF A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB NINE OH TWO TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM
AUTHORIZING THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO USE AN ALTERNATIVE DESIGN
BUILD CONTRACTING PROCESS. THE
DESIGN BUILD PROCUREMENT METHOD
PROVIDES SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THE USEFUL TOOL THAT RESULTS IN
EFFICIENCY AND COST SAVINGS. BY
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ENTER INTO EIGHT PARTNERSHIPS
WITH ENTITIES. THAT CAN BOTH
DESIGN AND BUILD SCHOOL
FACILITIES THE PARTIES CAN WORK
COOPERATIVELY THROUGH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION PHASES OF THE
PROJECT HOWEVER BOTH PARTIES
FACE UNCERTAINTY AT THE
INCEPTION OF DESIGN BUILD
PROJECT. MODERNIZING THE SCHOOL
CAMPUS IS OFTEN DONE IN PHASES
AND CAN SOMETIMES TAKE UP TO
EIGHT YEARS IT IS UNREASONABLE
TO HOLD THE CONTRACTOR TO HOLD
THE PRICE FOR A PROJECT THAT
WILL NOT BE COMPLETED UNTIL
EIGHT YEARS FROM NOW. THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS TO PAY FOR THE
ACTUAL VALUE OF THE WORK IN
STATE INSTEAD OF PAYING
CONTRACTORS A LOW COST WHEN THE
BIT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROJECT. AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
TRUST TRUSTED WITH PUBLIC
RESOURCES WE DO NOT WANT TO PAY
THEM LESS WERE OVERPAID BECAUSE
WE GUESSED WRONG. WE WANT TO PAY
MARKET VALUE FOR THE QUALITY OF
THE WORK PERFORMED. EIGHTY NINE
OH TWO WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND DESIGN BUILDERS TO
NEGOTIATE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION
COSTS ONCE THE DESIGN IS
COMPLETE. SINCE DESIGN BUILDERS
AND THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS WOULD
NO LONGER NEED TO ADD
CONTINGENCIES TO THEIR PROPOSALS
TO COVER FUTURE UNCERTAINTIES
THE FINAL CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE LOWER
RESULTING IN SAVINGS. FOR THE
REASONS TO INCREASE. EFFICIENCY
AND RESULT IN COST SAVINGS THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS PROUD TO SPONSOR.
EIGHTY NINE OH TWO AND URGES
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
PROTESTED DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
REAL. TESTIMONY FIVE FORTY THERE
ARE NO FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MR. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
ROOM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. GIVE US A MOMENT PLEASE TO-
SANITIZED. THANK YOU SIR AND
COULD YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF OF
THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
APOLOGIZE TO IN AND THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF FOR HIS
INTELLIGENCE- NEW PROCUREMENT
METHODS ARE DIFFICULT FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO KIND OF WRAP THEIR
HEADS AROUND- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING THEM WITH THEM WE HOPE
TO REACH A RESOLUTION. WE HAVE
NO ISSUE WITH- ALTERNATIVE
DESIGN BUILD PER SE ARE
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD. THE
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL A THE
MECHANICS OF HOW IT WOULD WORK.
AND SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH SUBCONTRACTORS YOU
CAN USE. WHERE THIS METHOD IS
USED IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR TODAY
THE OWNER COMES UP WITH THE
PRICE. IT'S UP TO THE DESIGN
BUILD TEAM TO MEET THAT PRICE IF
THEIR PRICES TOO HIGH THEN THE
TEAM ITSELF FINDS WAYS TO LOWER
IT. OR THEY CAN PART WAYS WITH
THAT TYPE OF APPROACH WE WOULD
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION. COMING IN THE
ROOM. SEEING NONE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MITCHELL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF DONALD I UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS BILL ALL WE EVER I
DON'T KNOW WHY. SEE THIS BILL AS
A NEEDED. ALL OVER JUST ENTER
THE WERE SO THIS BILL IS- GIVING
A REQUIRING- LABOR AGREEMENT-
OVER THAT THE PROJECTS OVER TEN
MILLION DOLLARS BUT WITHOUT THAT
THIS BILL WILL BE MORE
COMPETITIVE BASED UPON- DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE NON NON UNION WHEN IT
THE MORE ECONOMICAL BASED UPON
THEIR OPERATING COSTS OVER AT
THE THAN. WHAT THE COMPANY. SELL
ORGANIZED OR NOT. WELL THE BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE LABOR AGREEMENT
THERE IS OTHER LAW THAT DOES
REQUIRE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
WHAT THE BILL DOES DO THOUGH IT
REQUIRES- THAT A CONTRACTOR USE
A SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
FOUNDATIONAL TO ME THOSE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH. A
STATE CERTIFIED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT DELIVER- QUALITY
PROJECT ON TIME AND UNDER BUDGET
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR CHILDREN OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES NOTHING'S MORE
IMPORTANT RIGHT- MAN I WANT
THOSE BUILT WITH THE HIGHEST.
QUALITY SKILLED CRAFTSMEN ACROSS
WOMAN AS POSSIBLE AND IN MY
EXPERIENCE THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE STATE CERTIFIED.
PROGRAM SO BEFORE THIS BILL WITH
ANY PROBLEMS. PROBLEMS THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO USE THIS IT
IS THE THIS BILL WOULD CREATE AN
AVENUE ONE MORE PIECE OF POLICY
THAT SCHOOLS COULD USE TO
CONSTRUCT A CONSTRUCT OF
CELANESE IN IN IN WHAT I SEE AS
A- A MUCH MORE VALUABLE MANNER.
LIKELY SAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MONEY. IF THEY WERE TO BE AT THE
TABLE AND PARTICIPATE- MORE IN
THE IN THE IN THE BIDDING AND
ULTIMATELY THE COST. PROCESS OF
A SCHOOL FACILITIES. THANK YOU
MR O'DONNELL I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR YOU- NUMBER ONE
OVERALL I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
HAVE MADE THIS A PILOT PROGRAM
AND THAT YOU OF LIMITED TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF MY OWN. DID
YOU LIMIT IT TO A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF DISTRICTS- SO I APPRECIATE
BOTH OF THOSE EFFORTS- WHEN
YOU'RE MAKING A CHANGE LIKE THIS
AND THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE A
REPORT IT'S GOING TO COME OUT.
OF AND THAT THIS IS GOING TO
SUNSET- SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN REALLY LEARN ABOUT THIS NEW
PROCESS THE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT- AND I THINK THAT. COULD
BE HELPFUL FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IT MAY NOT BE WILL LOOK WE'LL
FIND OUT THAT'S WHAT THE PILOT
IS ALL ABOUT- ONE QUESTION DO
YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AT THE
COMMITTEE- HAS- PROVIDE YOU
MISTER BENNETT I DIFFERENT. AND
THEN A COULD YOU INFORM US HERE-
MISTER GOVERNOR SPOKE ABOUT-
ANOTHER AMENDMENT THAT HE WAS
WAS HOPING- FOR EXETER AND I
JUST LIKE CLARIFICATION MIGHT
FROM MY STANDPOINT. THIS IDEA
THAT THEY PICK THE
SUBCONTRACTORS OR THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FIX THE
SUBCONTRACTORS IS IT YOUR
INTENTION WAS TO BUILD TO TRY TO
SEE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SHOULD
PICK THE SUBCONTRACTORS. BECAUSE
YOU WANT THEM TO BE SKILLED AND
TRAINED OR IS THERE A DIFFERENT
REASON WHY YOU WANT THAT OR IS
THAT AN ACCURATE REPRESENTATION
OF YOUR BILL THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT PRESENTS AT COULD YOU
REALLY THE OVERALL EFFORT IS A
BILL TO ALLOW FOR DISTRICT
PARTICIPATION. TO ADDRESS THE
COSTS THE ULTIMATE COST OF A
PROJECT BUT AGAIN MISTER
GOVERNOR HAS COME FOR AND
BROUGHT UP SOME VALID POINTS
THAT I CAN SEE WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE DISCUSSIONS ON SO THE BILL
MAY WELL BE FURTHER AMENDED. AND
I'M QUITE OPEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THEY JUST CAME UP
A LITTLE QUICKER FOR US TO
REALLY. SETTLE ON WHAT THE
ULTIMATE THANK YOU HOW THE
LANGUAGE AGREED ANY. OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT- WE IT TO YOU FOR CLOSE
MISTER ARE JUST ASK FOR A- AS
FOR AYE VOTE CAN I DO A THE
AMOUNTS ARE AND WE'RE READY FOR
A OF MOTIONS. A SECOND- LAST
SECRETARY CULTURAL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN ITEMS YOU. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB NINE OH TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
O'DONNELL FIVE O'DONNELL AYE
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE CHAN.
CHOI CHOI NOT VOTING LEE LEE I
MCCARTY QUARK SILVA. QUICKSILVER
HI THE BILL HAS FOR BOTH OF THEM
. THANKS FOR RELIGION IT IS OUT
. CEMEX ROB. SO IF. FROM AROUND
ALL THIS PROJECT IS TO EIGHTY
YEARS. YEAH YEAH. OKAY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO THE CAN FILED
FORM ARE CONSENT- TO DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. REMOVED BY MR ONE
SECOND MY MISS COURTS SO. US
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE AND-
MEASURES OF THE I DON'T WANNA
MEASURES ON CONSENT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ONE OH TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB THREE TWENTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SEVEN
FORTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. HOW DONALD BY
O'DONNELL AYE BENNETT AYE
BENNETT AYE CHAN. CHOI CHOI I
LEAN. LEE AYE MCCARTY CORK SILVA
QUICKSILVER I THE BILL HAS FIVE
. SILICON VALLEY PASSES. I HAVE
NO CLUE. WELL DURING THE HEARING
THE ROLE OPEN. FIVE MEMBERS WISH
TO ADD ON ANY BILL PLEASE STAY
SEATED WITH YOUR MICROPHONES ON
STACY WITH IRAQ RUNS ON IF YOU
ARE NOT HERE FOR ALL THE BILLS-
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE SECRETARY
WILL. CALL THE ROLL CALL THE
ROLL FOR EACH. OF THOSE. HIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. WHAT.
SINESTRO IN CARE OF.